hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this time we're talking about
cmmc control
ac.l2-3.1.20 verify and control and
limit connections to and use of external
systems not internal but external I know
what's that
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliant stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you I'm
crazy and I make these videos no you
found your home here at on-call
compliant Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero and sometimes
make you laugh about a really boring
subject because compliance is so
exciting let's jump into it so in
cmmccontrol
ac.l1-3.1.20 verify and control limit
connections to and use of external
systems what they're looking for is for
you to demonstrate both an understanding
and an ability to control what your
users are actually connecting to on the
outside this control can definitely be a
challenging one to tackle because it's
so broad when you first look at it but
what we say what I say we do is this
let's check out what the assessors are
looking for on this one and how to make
them happy and I think the sample
answers in this case should shine some
light on everything for you now there's
a bunch of sample answers here and
hopefully I watched Sesame Street and I
can count it a lot because there's a lot
of assessment points very complicated
but I'm going to try to make it simple
so one two three four five six there are
six there's six this is four fingers
just in case you're ever wondered so I
have to use my other hand because
there's a hidden thumb back here and it
holds my pointer
four and two so I got six points we're
gonna talk about them all and we're
gonna tell you how an assessor would
look at this so
if I'm an assessor I am an assessor I'm
an assessment team member uh CCP
certified baby all right determine if
connections to external systems are
identified uh connections to external
systems are identified via again I just
give some random examples here right
like the organizational firewall your
seam Solutions you know if you don't
know that is go back and watch like 40
my other videos all right security
information event monitoring or
management uh solution endpoint
protection solution so again all of
these things act together uh to control
how you connect to external systems and
in some cases stop some of those
connections now assessment Point number
two determine if the use of external
systems is identified so if we're going
to identify how we do that well use of
external systems is identified via maybe
a seam solution right because you're
going to see exactly what's coming in is
it identified by IP address Mac address
it's going to show all that another way
that you could potentially answer that
is with firewall logs uh you know server
access logs lots and lots of options
there but again you have to show it you
have to show an assessor an example of
external systems being identified same
solution is probably your best bet
certainly an easy one
now the next one number one two three is
determinive can actually come on I got
like five and a half year old twins at
home I'm pretty good at by now right all
right comment below if you think that
was an awesome count count
all right it's not the wrong Sesame
Street I mean I'm like 40 years old I
I'm not gonna admit to really watching
Sesame Street on YouTube anyway
determinive connections to external
systems are verified connections to
external systems are verified by the
firewall and seam Solution that's a
pretty straightforward pretty easy
answer again that's what I would
demonstrate to an assessor via maybe
some shoulder surfing uh you know who
knows all right assessment Point number
four determine if the use of external
systems is verified all right ah now we
get a little bit more complex right if
we're going on to an external system is
there's some ability to verify uh that
we are actually you know going there
right so connections to external systems
are verified by the firewall right the
firewalls can usually authenticate
somehow or at least certainly do some
deep pack inspection and of course seam
Solutions going to also verify that
there was a successful external system
connection and verification there so
those are a couple of answers you could
certainly use different answers than
those lots and lots of ways to do that
but again those are a pretty simple way
to answer that
assessment Point number five determinive
connections to the external systems are
controlled slash limited uh again pretty
easy and straightforward answer there
because uh that's what a firewall does
right connections to external systems
are controlled limited by the firewall
right You've Got Deep you know deep
packet inspection you've got intrusion
prevention you've got all kinds of other
things in there that are essentially
controlling and limiting what systems
you can connect to and if it's malicious
hopefully it's stopping you from making
that connection now I could have
answered another way right maybe you
don't have a firewall like a physical
on-premise type firewall like a Florida
gate or a Sophos unit we're big fans of
Sophos here uh maybe instead you have an
endpoint management Solution that's
managing the local firewall on your
computer that's okay too so again lots
of ways you can demonstrate to an
assessor that that is being met
the sixth and final one is determine if
the use of external systems is
controlled and limited right great
example here is a web filter right are
you controlling the ability to go to
certain websites uh maybe you've got
port and protocol control are you
controlling the ability to go to an
external system through various ports uh
or disallowing certain protocols like
maybe we don't want to go into Gmail we
want to limit that capability so again
those are a couple of sample ideas
sample answers there we might answer
very simply with connections to external
systems are limited and controlled by
the organization's firewall that would
be pretty simple just be prepared to Dem
to to demonstrate this one to an
assessor I think this is one that you
know an interview may not really be good
enough for you're probably looking at
the idea of a little bit of shoulder
surfing a little bit of demonstration
virtually on this control now at on call
we work with defense contractors just
like you that's you it's something I'm
sitting behind you not your boss in
front of you it's you we work with you
who have had this D fars nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped into their
lab like a seagull on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas in
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
I know sounds crazy compliance leads to
more Defense work and we can show you
how with higher profit margins yes if
you're more secure you're more valuable
believe me how secure you are on a DOD
purchasing Matrix looks pretty similar
to what the whole cost is all right
literally you can't even do business
with you if you're not secure and the
price is a variable now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you we drop knowledge like that
a lot okay so again we're all about
helping our clients grow now if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com okay cmmc compliance
secrets.com is where you go if you don't
want to deal with this all right if you
don't want to deal with it you just want
this done for you go to that website
book a time with one of our with one of
our certified compliance experts all
right and check out the bio below for
more links on how to get help right now
if you love the content we're putting
out here for you or just don't want to
do this stuff yourself help us out with
a big thumbs up on that like button you
know we're trying to feel the love out
there we're trying to deliver it all to
you uh again a thumbs up on that like
button seriously it really helps us out
even better Mash that subscribe button
I'm gonna drop the S I'm just gonna mash
it mash it in the ground subscribe again
go get another Google account subscribe
again it all helps guys to get the
latest compliance content as soon as our
compliances roll it out
or we just decided it's a really great
time to shamelessly plug ourselves over
and over and over and over again because
you know what to be honest it's just fun
it's fun to do it's kind of hilarious
until the next compliance tip my friends
stay safe and secure out there hit us in
the comments below to let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance and yes sir I'll see you on
the next one
[Music]